what's going on guys this is rob and in
this video i'm going to make you guys an
expert on mobius m
mobius but in order to beef this video
up because there's not a whole lot about
his character we're also going to cover
other members of the time variance
authority there is a kind of hierarchy
here but not really
it's just one of those instances where
we've seen like higher ranking people
above
mobius basically appear in comics as
well as other characters who have
appeared that basically serve different
purposes
right so uh let's talk about mobius and
mobius one of the things to know about
the time variance authority and we
covered this
in our video explaining the
organizations you can find the link to
that down in the description
the whole idea is that because there are
so many alternate realities out there
there really just aren't enough people
to really staff the entirety of the tva
and so what they actually end up doing
is basically cloning themselves right so
mobius immobius is just the name of a
particular clone the entire tva is
filled with clones of mobius and really
he's just a clone of others right so
if the the marvel cinematic universe and
the loki tv show actually covered or
really matched the comics for what we
had
you would have seen like a million owen
wilson's just walking around the whole
thing about this
is that mobius mobius is really the more
prominent member of the tva
because he's dealt with different heroes
like the fantastic four and different
things along those lines now his history
largely goes in line with the nature of
the time variance authority which is to
say
they're an organization that was tasked
to basically ensure that like alternate
realities are not really created
arbitrarily that people kind of follow
the rules of the timeline or the rules
of the multiverse that kind of thing
at least in terms of how it pertains to
time they really
are not an organization that serves to
make sure people don't cross over
into other universes there are other
organizations that serve that purpose
they're not really in charge of making
sure that universes
evolve the way they're supposed to
that's you know again a group like the
omniversal development court that kind
of a thing but nonetheless the
nature of mobius is that he appeared
largely in fantastic four comics and
that was just the results of the
fantastic four
altering the time stream or doing
something that would change the flow of
time that would alter the future of the
universe and what it was supposed to be
from its set path
and so he hadn't really appeared a whole
lot and in fact the only real
appearances he had
came in fantastic four 353 what if
number 39 fantastic four annual number
27
unlimited access number two the
fantastic four marvel knights comic with
issue number 15 and issue number 18
and then she-hulk vol 2 with issues
three through four and that was
basically it right this guy's appeared
very few times in marvel comics it's
just one of these things where whenever
things pop off with the tva
he's usually the first person that you
see now above mobius immobius you have a
guy named mr
alternity now mr alternity we're not
really giving a whole lot of indication
there he showed up in fantastic four
annual number 27
and the fantastic four marvel knights
comic with issue number 18. the whole
idea behind him though is that all we
really knew
is that somewhere along the line that
movies had actually been offered a job
by king the conqueror and he was gonna
take it until you ultimately had mr
alternity who quite literally
had to match the job offer to keep
mobius and a lot of that was rooted in
the fact that while mobius is
technically a clone he loves the idea of
details right he relishes in details and
because of that attention to detail he's
a much desired member of the tva now
this also leads me to talk a little bit
about king the conqueror we're not going
to go super in-depth into him
he really needs a video unto himself to
really understand kang because there's
so much that goes on there which we will
do but the important thing here is that
when it comes to the multiverse you can
almost look at it as like a massive
expansion on earth you know at a
previous point in time you had like the
british empire and the french
empire and the spanish empire the
multiverse is the exact same way that
you've got the time variance authority
which you can kind of consider really
more of almost like a government agency
and it was designed to illustrate the
ineffectiveness of like government
bureaucracy but then you also have kane
the conquerors
empire and kane the conqueror rules
entire universes right whole universes
have been conquered by king the
conqueror and he rules them all as part
of his own empire he's always at odds
with the tva and then you've got other
organizations that kind of rule these
small little sections or at least have
influence
in these small little sections of the
the multiverse so uh the universal
church of truth
exists in multiple realities the
omniversal development court roma and
merlin like you have all these different
kind of organizations groups individuals
that have a hand
and what goes on across there but then
following mr alternity you really have a
guy that kind of falls below mobius and
mobius which is a guy by the name of
mr tesseract now much like mr alternity
this guy
appeared once and it was in fantastic
four annual number 27 and that was it
right and the only thing you really knew
about him is that somewhere along the
line because of the fantastic four's
actions which actually kind of coalesced
in in fantastic four annual number 27
a bunch of information regarding the
future of the main marvel universe had
basically been lost well really not even
the future across the entire timeline
what kinds of things that unfolded how
things were supposed to unfold over the
course of the future it was almost in a
lot of ways to kind of void when it came
to the time variance authority because
they just didn't really have the
information that they needed this guy's
job was to basically just reconstruct
all the data and that was essentially it
right just to kind of bring all that
information back
and essentially give the tva the ability
to ensure the universe function the way
it was supposed to now the next guy
after this is really a guy named mr
paradox and this guy was cool so the
cool thing about this is that in
she-hulk volume 2 in the first three
issues you had a story called the trial
of she-hulk and the way this worked is
that there was a man who had committed a
murder
and the idea was that there was no one
who was left alive that could testify to
his claim
that there was a time traveler involved
and so what ended up happening
is the time variance authority was
invoked to basically grab people from
the past and bring them to the present
so they could testify
on this man's behalf because he deserved
a fair trial the funny thing about this
is that the tva can do that and there
are times when you can go to the tva
and you can plead your case and that if
your case is accepted they'll actually
allow you to time travel if you need to
it's only under the most extreme
circumstances that they do that but
that's the nature of the tva right like
time travel is entirely possible but it
has to be done
under the supervision of the time
variance authority either that or marvel
uses a plot device and when the
question's asked well why didn't the tva
show up
it's chalked up to the idea of well
because they were supposed to right it
was supposed to happen and so there was
no reason for the tva to get involved
pretty much the same line of logic that
you saw in the loki tv show
the avengers were supposed to go back in
time you know which is kind of
interesting thing a little bit of a
sidetrack here for a second a big plot
hole that i noticed
is that loki was right when he said that
like if the avengers were supposed to go
back in time
during the events of infinity war and
avengers in game and that they were
supposed to grab the infinity stones
from different time periods and they
were supposed to go to the present day
basically undo this snap and then
destroy thanos and his army and then put
the infinity stones back to where they
were supposed to be
there was no point in that where the
entire process saw tony stark
undo the conversation with his father or
saw captain america
undo the moment when he told his past
counterpart that bucky was still alive
and so if all that was supposed to
happen
it stands to reason loki was supposed to
get the tesseract and loki was supposed
to use it to escape right so it's one of
those things where it seems like the
marvel cinematic universe is just kind
of arbitrarily picking and choosing
what things are supposed to work and
what things are not for the sake of
telling a story it's the nature of
things but nonetheless back on track the
whole idea behind this is when the tva
grabbed people from the past
and brought them to the present to
testify on this guy's behalf that one of
those individuals was clint barton was
hawkeye who had basically been gone he'd
been dead since the events of house of m
and so what ended up happening here is
jennifer walters kept trying to warn him
that he was going to die the time
various authority saw this as an
attempted modification of the timeline
so she-hulk
was put on trial and initially she was
gonna be destroyed
they were gonna kill her off ended up
being some crazy villain by the name of
clockwise just started going through and
shooting everybody
and that basically led to the death of
mr paradox as well as another guy
named ora boris who are basically just
vanished from existence by what was
called a rat can machine which is
essentially a device like a giant cannon
it literally is a giant cannon that if
you
fire it at somebody because it's the
most powerful weapon of the tva what it
does
is it actually sends you backward
through time until you cease to exist so
it basically wipes you from existence
and it also undoes
every single encounter that you ever had
with anybody so nobody ever met you
right because one of the biggest issues
is the time variance authority just
white jennifer walters from existence
just got rid of she-hulk then people
would start asking where she was but if
they hit her with the retcon cannon then
what it would basically do is send her
backward through time so that it was
like she never existed that nobody ever
heard of her nobody knows who she is
not even bruce banner would know about
it he would never be aware that he ever
had a cousin right it's just one of
those things where
she just kind of ceases to exist now
that would arguably create even more
changes to the timeline but presumably
the tva knows what those are going to be
but these two guys again this is not
really a hierarchy it's not really a
list
of the most powerful members of the time
variance authority
ranking from you know strongest to
weakest but again all these guys that
we've listed here with the exception of
mr alternity are basically just clone
variants of mobius and mobius they all
look exactly like him right they they
all look almost identical to each other
right
or at least they are identical because
they're all clones and so following that
there is some stuff out there that you
guys are already aware of the minutemen
who are basically the
the long arm of the law when it comes to
the tda they're what stands for like
a time-based police force essentially
but again it's kind of an interesting
concept one of the questions that i've
seen a lot of people ask is what are the
powers of the tva the tva has the
ability to manipulate time
and they're probably or at least
arguably one of the most powerful beings
in all of existence
if they can alter the entirety of the
timeline they can just make you make you
non-existent that's why even the most
powerful characters who exist out there
outside of maybe people like kang or
people that have absolute control over
time
won't really mess with the tva because
if somebody like matthew malloy who has
the ability to resurrect himself from
the dead or somebody like the marquee of
death who can wipe out
whole universes with a wave of his hand
even despite the power that they have
all the tva has to do is just
go back in time and keep them from
existing and they're gone right so like
literally the ability to manipulate time
is arguably the most powerful force in
the entirety of marvel comics because
what good is an opponent if they never
existed in the first place so with that
being said guys i know it's a pretty
short video but again
there's so little info about the tva
that it just becomes kind of wonky and a
little difficult to explain so anyway
guys i'm gonna wrap this up thank you
guys for watching and i will catch you
all later
peace